when you think about what makes a
university great it's really not a
homogeneous community it's a diverse
community that makes us so so so
significantly stronger from the
standpoint of women we're certainly
seeing not necessarily a huge increase
in the number of women applying but
where the increase is coming is
ultimately in the high quality women
that are applying we're seeing greater
numbers of those students and so as a
result we're able to admit more women
which is translating it into ultimately
enrolling more women the yield has gone
up for women as well and so they're
certainly seeing Carnegie Mellon perhaps
differently than maybe some of their
predecessors recognizing that this is a
community that does care an awful lot
about underrepresented populations and
particularly in our STEM disciplines
women had been underrepresented and even
in the Tempur school we have seen
significant growth in terms of the yield
in women and so it's really you know
from my standpoint terrific having been
here for so long at Carnegie Mellon
recognizing the huge gains that we've
been making in this area in such a short
amount of time I've got to say we know
we're pretty proud of the advances that
we're making and I think that it makes a
difference in the university community I
can't tell you how many faculty have
reiterated how important it is to have
women you know represent it in a way
where the strengths of those students
come out and so I think the critical
mass issue is behind us and we have I
think a great group of women that are
joining the community this year one of
the things that I love about being an
undergraduate admission is you know
really we're opportunity brokers really
we're really you know providing
opportunities for students that may
never have thought about you know a kind
of an experience like this and so
there's no better time to be an
undergraduate admission quite frankly
and and I think in no better place than
at Carnegie Mellon